[Applause]
got to show you this waiting thing
you're being honored
you will be presented from a lifetime
achievement award so what you told a
mouse is 24/7 driving slate for the
entire weekend look who the previous
winners are Robert De Niro Jack
Nicholson and Clint Eastwood Oh what hi
Edwards yeah you should see this rathole
you're there already just what the hell
is this this is the festival welcome to
Nashville we are too heavy here aria
thank you for coming to the Film Fest
wait let's get you over the red carpet
[Music]
but how are you even here because
Clinton Jack and Bobby DeNiro one you
are the only one stupid enough to show
up there are things I've go where's Vic
he left
Vic washed you bang bang OH
oh my god back entire bazooka has been
the number one box office star for five
years in a row six six I'm sorry better
choice to take the next action takes are
different
where are you going he's on some weird
memory tour or something God who you are
I can't believe it is it true that you
doubled Burt Lancaster had to double
somebody on that picture I had a fall
off a horse in a dress an audience will
forgive a shitty act - she's been Wow in
act 3
The Hollywood Critics Association
awarded you best newcomer of the year
that's the only time I ever agreed with
the critic
you